I appreciate you laughing because I was
booed on stage last week you know
I had a benefit
so I was booed downstairs for free
that's what upset me and I knew I was
going to get food because I was an
opening act for Snoop Dogg where no one
knew he had to clean Christian common so
when they lowered the lights people were
going wait what snow we want Snoop wave
once nope MC came out are you ready for
Snoop Dogg yeah
are you ready for Snoop Dogg yeah okay
but first
didn't even get my name right here's
Andy Griffith
your brother's going booed for Mayberry
[Applause]
they look different on TV
how many of y'all broke in here
right on pause how many broke people
good so y'all can relate to this [ __ ]
right here cause I'm telling you I've
been broke for so long man I forgot what
it's like to tell people to keep your
change
I'm saying you go to the store you buy
something that costs 99 cents you give
them a dollar and you wait for that
change
did that money add up don't it that
money will add up when you go to the
Koreans they gonna want that change
you better have it I'm serious and then
when you're broke you're gonna have
broke friends how many of y'all got
broke friends by round of applause
well that's good for you good for you
but see when you got bro friends they
gonna keep you bro
[Music]
all right this on TV we ain't booing all
right we ain't booing I know it's late
they gonna edit this part of the show
it's late y'all been all night waiting
I've been waiting too so just be patient
if y'all don't mind all right appreciate
that thank y'all very much because I am
funny I did these jokes last night and
they worked all right it's just late
it's just late
it's just a little bit late right now
all right but we're gonna work it out
so y'all still with me Uptown y'all
still with me
all right let's do this [ __ ] let's do
this [ __ ] so coming to the stage right
now all the way from L.A
committee Mr Kenny strong y'all give it
up put your hands together
you know when you're broke
my friends y'all
so y'all ain't right y'all ain't right
y'all y'all make a [ __ ] want to just
change a career
in a minute you know what I'm saying
so anyway
I'm gonna work this [ __ ] out work this
[ __ ] out y'all ain't gonna run a [ __ ]
off stage [ __ ] that I'm from L.A they
gotta bring the worst [ __ ] than that
[Music]
[ __ ] that
[Music]
we're gonna We Gonna Roll this you know
what I'll tell you what we're gonna come
back on the next tape and y'all have a
good night
[Applause]
[Music]
and I did my first joke which I didn't
realize they were playing in the
advertising on the radio so everyone
already heard it and nobody
laughed
and I was like literally I was like
already neck deep and it was so long ago
and then I just remember I went to
another joke and I just bailed halfway
through I was like you guys aren't going
to laugh at that and then they booed and
um let's maybe we should roll the table
I don't want to see this
I think you guys want to see it a bunch
of [ __ ] losers
[Applause]
built around a [ __ ] now doesn't even
exist
[Applause]
it exists you can't [ __ ] deal with
[Applause]
[Music]
them
[ __ ] slaps you on the back of your zit
your shoulders
[Music]
[Applause]
seven minutes left
for three hours to get booed by this GD
[ __ ] stupid ass piece of [ __ ]
left and I will be selling
my application
one minute left in the period
this doesn't change anything in this set
I still [ __ ] hate you people
in Rocking 19. oh good good
[Applause]
if you guys
I've never seen that are you serious
I've never seen that no really no
so did you decide to do the countdown
before you went out I mean is that
something you no no no what happened was
luckily I had been booed before so it
wasn't a new thing so the first time you
get booed is a you know it's a hell of
an experience because you have what you
want but it's the exact opposite emotion
you have the entire crowd's Focus except
it's no love it's just hate so the first
time that happens it's really uh I
didn't know what to do but I I also I
remember just afterwards
thinking about it going like why didn't
I I let that fat guy boo me I let that
chick with the weird glasses like why
didn't I say something
I just remember thinking I was just mad
at myself going like all right you got
booed you know they didn't think you
were funny
um but you sat there and you know it was
a variety show they had like a
contortionist and somebody with a snake
and then somebody saying saying like
Pour some sugar on me and look at these
leather pants and then they'd bring a
comedian out it was just it was a
complete [ __ ] show
so I just remember afterwards I just
remember being like upset at myself that
I that I I was like dude you could at
least throw one punch you should have
done that but but but then I didn't
think of it again I didn't think of it
again because uh you know you don't plan
on something like that happening so I
don't know why I did that I just started
doing it and that they had the clock was
there
and I was just looking at it and I I
just I don't know I think in that moment
I decided I wasn't going to leave so I
think the countdown was kind of for me
like you're doing cardio you know that
and you're like I'm not going to look
for one song you know and then look all
right another three minutes went off so
here's the funny thing so we still had
one more date on that tour something was
telling me don't do the last one and
then I went to Cleveland
and it was like as I walked out on stage
everybody booed because they wanted me
to trash their city
so then it became this thing's like I
can't do this again or then this is my
act this is like Gallagher smashing the
Watermelons I gotta come out and read
about all your sports teams and [ __ ] so
that was the one I freaked out about
because I thought it was like I thought
my career was over I was like everywhere
I go I'm going to get booed and blah
blah blah I'm glad that people enjoyed
it because I was definitely I was
embarrassed that the whole thing
happened this weekend veteran news
Anchorman David Brinkley apologized to
Bill Clinton for an election night
commentary in which he called the
president quote boring and uncreative
admitted brinkly there was certainly
nothing uncreative about the way you
moved Vince Foster's body
president's a murderer you didn't know
that
[Applause]
man I'm nervous
I can literally hear my dad up in heaven
right now like boy you better not mess
this up
a lot of crazy
now Donald Trump is president
[Applause]
nah calm down I'm not as mad as Facebook
is
you read the messages oh Donald Trump
that's the worst president ever I'm not
the smartest man but 400 years of
slavery and not one of them presidents
made the cut
and the worst part is I feel like I
understand really what's the problem
with Donald Trump
everybody here in America knows the code
if you get caught cheating you gotta cut
your side thing loops
Donald Trump still on the phone at the
White House talking to Russia hello
hey no no I want to talk to my man right
now you go get my poop
is that you my poop
I love you so much
I love the way you smell
I love the way your name comes off my
lips
boom
oh
um
sit down sit down
[Applause]
sit down
[Music]
and he walked off stage
I should have done that [ __ ]
[Applause]
tonight
do that
you're pulling yourself
oh wow what a piece of [ __ ]
what a piece of [ __ ]
what a piece of [ __ ]
he's [ __ ] [ __ ]
[Music]
on the paper tomorrow
I'm from Chicago born and raised
yes sir yes sir
if it's one thing I've learned being
from Chicago is that when you from
Chicago you can't go nowhere else and
get cold
now people act like something wrong with
you if you catch a chill cause we
supposed to be Invincible to the cold
[ __ ] see me outside and say stupid
[ __ ] to me like hey man it's 30 degrees
out here I bet this feel like somebody
you don't it no [ __ ] feel like cold
just like I do to you stupid
what the [ __ ] are you talking about
people always say dumb [ __ ] like the
other day I was outside the comedy club
I'm hanging with some [ __ ] I'm like
that's a little chilly out here I'm
gonna run to the car and get my coat I'm
cold [ __ ] look at me and say you cold
[ __ ] ain't you from Chicago
you should be used to the cold
really say [ __ ] that's the stupidest
[ __ ] I've ever heard in my life how the
[ __ ] where you from you don't get used
to the cold that's like being out with a
[ __ ] that been shot five times and
somebody starts shooting in the club he
take off running if you catch him in the
hallway like [ __ ] for real you scared
[Applause]
everything all right back there yeah
oh
oh [ __ ] oh that's for me y'all y'all
don't like something I'm saying
[Music]
oh well what the [ __ ] y'all want to talk
about Tim
[Applause]
I made the joke about it now [ __ ] it
since you don't like the [ __ ] I got tell
me what you want to hear about it
huh
[Applause]
say what Your Heroes
[Applause]
listen
[Applause]
okay okay okay all right all right let's
let's bring it down a notch
oh
it's all right well [ __ ] what God never
did somebody
you don't want to give me [ __ ] to talk
about you don't want to hear the [ __ ]
I'm talking about it just ain't run
right in this [ __ ]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
I'm sorry I I apologize